♪ [music] ♪
Looking to accelerate
your open-source data
and analytics processing?
Give me one minute
and I'll show you how with Cloud Dataproc.
Dataproc is a managed service
for any OSS jobs
that support big data processing
including ETL and machine learning.
It provides out-of-the-box support
for the most popular open-source software.
You can use Dataproc
to move your on premise OSS clusters
to the cloud,
to maximize efficiency and enable scale.
Or, use it with Cloud AI Notebook
or BigQuery
to build an end-to-end
data science environment.
With Dataproc, you can spin up
an IT governed, auto-scaling cluster
in just 90 seconds.
It manages the cluster creation,
monitoring,
and job orchestration for you.
Start by creating a cluster
through the web UI, Cloud SDK,
REST APIs, or with SSH access.
Once your cluster's provisioned,
you can submit jobs
in your opensource framework of choice.
Scale your cluster up or down at any time
even when jobs are running
and you'll pay only for what you use
down to the second.
Next time you're looking
to simplify your data
and analytics processing,
take a minute to look at Dataproc.
To learn more, check out
cloud.google.com/dataproc.